Jaakko as a leader at what point am I
allowed to go to others and say I need
you because I recognize I'm not capable
of pushing toward forward on my own or
should that be an instance where I need
to take a step back and apply more
discipline to my life
and find a way to push forward by myself
okay
you are allowed to say that to your team
member immediately that you need them
absolutely if you of course you need
your team because if you didn't need
your team why would they be there yeah
if you if you can do everything yourself
then you don't have a team Yeah right
you just do everything yourself
so while you of course should be working
hard you should be applying discipline
as a leader it's your job to actually
lead things and to let other people
support and make things happen and
there's nothing wrong with that you and
also you don't want to be stuck in the
weeds doing my new thing so if you're
not capable I think what might be
holding this individual back there's two
things number one is I feel like I
should take extreme ownership of
everything yeah I feel like I should do
everything myself that is not what
extreme ownership is extremely tough
isn't doing everything yourself and also
what can come into play is your ego
because you don't wanna ask people for
help and that's not a good sign
there's nothing wrong with asking people
for help if you need it in fact that's
the humble thing to do hey echo I don't
know how to quite finish out this you
know this thing of this project Morgan
how can you give me a hand with this I
don't know how to work a video recorder
can you show me how to do that right
whatever so there's no problem with that
you're allowed to ask you can you can
say that immediately in fact your team
should feel that you are counting on
them and relying on them they should
know that and then put your ego aside
ask for help no problem that doesn't
mean you're giving away that doesn't
mean you're not taking ownership that
doesn't mean you're not applying
discipline it means you're working as a
team together to accomplish mission
again if a if a mission is so easily
that you can accomplish it yourself you
don't need a team why do you have them
hmm
if you can do it all yourself just by
applying discipline cool you don't need
anyone else if you're you but your
mission should be larger than one human
being can accomplish so that's why you
have other people on board to help you
out yeah no problem
you know like I always think wouldn't
one that I thought we made it out of
that question go ahead no but you know I
like let's say it's like something
that's just a pain in the ass and you
don't really need help but you just
don't want to do about yourself ok well
then yeah the need then you gotta do
that yourself ah yes yeah yeah so that's
kind of where this is coming from
ultimately because it's like I'm not
saying that if you're the if you're if
you have a position in a company where
you shouldn't be doing some sort of task
because it's not financially efficient
to have you know a person that's making
a a hundred and fifty thousand dollars a
year doing a task that someone that's
making $10 an hour should be doing
mm-hmm so you shouldn't do that that's
not what I'm advocating and a company
won't won't be doing well yeah if you're
paying people a hundred fifty thousand
dollars a year that you could get
someone to do for $10 an hour I'm not
saying that mmm so don't get me wrong
yeah but that's why we have a team so
that you can focus on going forward and
whatever it is you need to be focused on
and somebody that's below you in the
chain of command that's a member of your
team that's getting paid $10 an hour can
do some of the stuff that you needed me
to do yeah yeah and the the question
actually is really clear because it's
because quote-unquote because I
recognize I'm not capable of pushing you
know it's kind of like it's obvious to
you that you need help it's not that
you're you know raking leaves and I
don't want to do this all by myself
so hey you know you tell your brother
come help me it's not that it's
different yeah and if you need to get
the leaves raked and and you need them
done by Monday so you can get them in
the bags so that the dump truck can come
and take the leaves away mm-hm and you
can't physically get it done then you're
you say to your brother hey can you give
me Hannah do you get these done tonight
before the Sun Goes Down
yeah I'm walking able to make it in time
can you give me a hand yeah your brother
says absolutely yeah doctor back